what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to i want to say this is
like handball afl i don't even know one
of my subscribers sent me this video so
the people ask and i deliver before i
start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos while you're at it yo i
made these sweatshirts they're fire
literally go with anything blue
black i love them
um you can only buy them for like three
more days so go buy one the link's in my
biome
anyways
um i hate sports so i am ready to be
bored
good bounce too what the dawn kept out
of it mcrae came in nice and hard gone
went back and found it and then oliver
got taken in a really good wow
liberator going to work early
great forward
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay i'm so confused by this sport it's
like football and handball combined
first
ruckman are back a long way they started
their running the goals where neither of
them went the front position
in the end they're a little bit late
arriving at the footy
viny
i mean he's dead the only deploy only
father-son to play 150 for the demons
little tip over the top is good
here they go once again inside 50 and
the mark is taken right on the line by
fridge
this kick has to go into this spot right
here oh wow jackie being muscled english
from the side there were three big dogs
up then liberatore at the front got a
three on one three on oh it looks good
is that impressive the
i guess that was good okay
oh wow he's so excited
the all australian jake lever
long and wide gourd front and center
what about that
bouncing inside 50 look out
in the air oh oh my god he ran so fast
so careful why
oh because he's so close to the
oh it's like soccer too
so it's like soccer flip oh my gosh
eventually
dunkley
had too much on it bowie's going to
bring it back in half cena forward
lowers the eyes not great
mr martin williams and
norton how many how many people are on
the field at a time
there's so many people
high ball inside 50.
[Applause]
fish to the front
[Applause]
got to get the fist to it there's good
representation here for the dogs
hannah flicks it to hunter
left foot up
slides it back to our hot spot
a hot spot
like my phone hot spot
oh good job
he's just missed it
is it like a field goal
oh my god i'm confused
[Applause]
now the lower ball norton at the back in
the front was bottom valley
four goals to one in the first quarter
for the demons it may be four goals to
one in the second for the dogs
it is indeed
for his second of the term and for the
dog six
[Applause]
ahead of the footy
oh that was a cool catch
that was cool i'm gonna give you that
was a good penetrating kick from
what a great match oh wow that was
seven goals three to one goal five since
quarter time
to rock smith who released the footy
somehow i'm not quite sure
they've still got it inside 50
williams taking in attack all look out
this is some game he's playing
they're just one goal away from
exploding again i reckon
but they need to oh
that was not nice
on earth
[Applause]
okay this sport is so boring like
there can't be a lot of people that
watch this
[Music]
[Applause]
jackson to the front fine he went
without through came smith harms now
a long one into space friction the best
position possible
they need the next one or the one after
even two out of the three oliver here
they come patrick
first goal from center circle clearance
there for melbourne six with the prelim
here's another look
long one
benny brown
there we are
can they find another one here melbourne
they've kicked the last four of this
game oh wow long ball picking at the
back
oh wow
how good is that
you absolutely kicking it or can you
just run over the finish line
six clearances as well he's got both of
them
petrarca and bonham pelly going head to
head there he is to oliver again this
one will be a big one
to make it a three goal three four
what happens if the other team catches
it over the line i'm assuming it's like
soccer where it's still in
little one from barney
[Applause]
um oh oh there's there's more
yay
of sparrow in the
forward pocket half forward high one for
benny brown
[Applause]
they've done so much defending back half
of this game they break this one up as
well keith flicks the handball through
and the dogs can bring it away but so
much
ahead of the ball is stagnant there you
go
petrarcha strips it
and look at the vision of christian
petra
goes long and ahead of jackson 40 from
the side with a big spoil norton was
there little one here from neil bullan
got it out wide found some space for
jackson he's skidded over salem he wants
a piece of the action he's got it as
well
he has got it
brown
to brace all
sparrow working hard and fritz is going
to get another look
john mcdonnell times the ticking
every heart is beating true and blue for
the red and blue
oh yeah
[Applause]
oh my god that was like the most boring
seven minutes of my life i do not
understand oh gosh what did i click i do
not understand how people watch sports i
don't
um i've always been a player i've never
coached
yeah um if you if you like
reactions of me being bored
let me know in the comments you know i
give the people what they want but yeah
um don't forget to subscribe feel free
to cop a sweatshirt thanks guys